INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
So, in today's
video, we're going
to be switching
gears a little bit,
but still keeping in this mind
frame of web development, web
deployment.
And specifically, I want to
talk about a different framework
for passing along
information on the web.
So we've talked
about now how do we
build a website, a
simple website, and pass,
or deploy that publicly so
that our users can access it.
And you can almost think about
this as a form of machine
to human communication
in a sense.
It's like we have a
server that has content,
has information on there,
whatever our website has,
whether that be our resume,
the weather for the day,
whatever that might be.
That is the machine
side of things.
And then the browser
displays that to the user.
So we build the HTML
so that the user can
or whatever the front-end code
is that the user can view that.
That's great.
That solves a lot of
problems, and honestly,
handles a good bit of
what happens on the web.
But there's another side of this
where we might want to be able,
or might want to have a platform
where our server can pass along
information to another
computer to another machine.
That might be just a step in the
chain to displaying the website,
but it is still
a necessary step.
Is that I don't really need to
return information to the user
yet.
I just need to pass this
on to another machine.
And so in that
context, a website
doesn't actually serve
that purpose well.
So take again for
example, our resume.
Maybe we wanted to have this
hosted live so that a recruiter
could view that.
But if, for example,
we actually had
a website that had a
bunch of resumes on it,
and we wanted to pass
those resumes off to,
I don't know, Workday or
some other HR software
that displays this
information for a recruiter
to see if a bunch of
different resumes.
That's actually not
the best way to do it.
Have a bunch of links
to personal websites.
Because then the Workday
would have to go and scrape
all of these websites,
extract all that information
coming from a variety
of different formats.
And then somehow
structure it again.
And so we can
consistently see, well,
this person who called
their work experience,
work experience versus
this other person
called it, I don't
know portfolio,
or whatever it might be.
We now, all of a sudden,
have to figure out how
to structure that information.
So there's a
different methodology
that's used for this.
And it's called an API,
an application programming
interface.
You may have heard
this term already,
or you may already be very,
very familiar with it.
If you're already
familiar with them, great.
You can skip ahead
to later topic.
But for those that
are new to it,
this is a really clever
idea that basically says,
hey, what if instead of worrying
about the user interface
side of this, we're just
creating a platform where
a server can request
information from another server
and have that returned in
a nice structured format.
And so that really,
really helps us
build very flexible platforms.
And for that matter,
too, it may even
be a situation where we want to
have our own application built
off of our own APIs.
So take, for example, a case
where I'm building a mobile app,
let's say, something
like Airbnb.
I might want to have a mobile
application for Airbnb.
I might want to have
a website for Airbnb.
I might want to have a
whole slew of different ways
to display the information
that's on that website.
Rather than having to rebuild
the same platform over and over
again, where we have all
of our images in one place,
and all the content of all
our listings in one place,
and then have to duplicate
that work over again,
or rewrite the code so that I
can pull it from the database
and structure that.
I can build an API for myself
that says, hey, what it does
is it serves information.
All I have to do is
request information.
It serves information
back to me.
It's a very, very simple
idea in that sense.
You can almost think
about it like a menu.
You have a list of
things you can do here,
like a list of requests that you
can make or a list of endpoints
is what we'll call them in APIs.
We have a list of endpoints.
And the client, in this
case, in the case of a menu,
it's a customer.
It can make a request.
And then the chef will
return that information.
Sometimes it requires
you to put information,
or maybe I need to
pass along information
of my dietary
restriction, and then
say, given these
dietary restrictions,
return me this information.
But that's what an API is
doing is basically just
handling requests and
returning information.
The same way we were doing
with our HTML websites,
which it took requests.
And then we returned the
HTML for the website.
This is submitting a
request and returning
a text-based format or some
sort of structured format.
There's a bunch of really
popular APIs out there.
Let me see.
I had a few up here.
Let me pull them up again.
Notice as well, I got
an EC2 instance launch.
We'll get to that in a second.
But this site just lists a bunch
of basically the most popular
APIs right now.
This was 2022 actually.
So a couple of years ago.
But we have things like
one to connect to TikTok.
So to pull information
from TikTok.
So you can see, for example,
they have a bunch of endpoints
there where I can pull
trending information,
hashtag IDs, music IDs, videos,
search effects users, or Google
search, which allows me to
basically embed Google search
into another application.
So even if I have some other app
that I'm building that requires,
or it would be benefited by
having Google search in there
rather than having to rebuild
the entirety of search
and Google myself, I can
just tap into their endpoints
where basically I'll pass
on the user's search query.
I'll put that search
query over to Google here.
And then it will
complete that web search.
It'll return the information in
some structured format for me
to return to my user.
Therefore, I'm
still using Google.
But I don't have to actually
pass that user off or hand them
off to Google in a
really clunky way.
You have a lot of
things like sports.
So this is for
football, for soccer.
So if I want to grab information
about specific soccer games,
I can grab statistics,
player info, lineups,
all these sorts of details.
And so rather than,
again, having a website
where the user has
to go on there,
and scroll and filter, and
click through all this,
I might have some
other application
that is supposed to just list
local soccer games for me
and pull pass statistics.
I don't have to build
any of that now.
I can just tap into
these APIs endpoints.
So it's a really, really useful,
flexible platform to use,
or framework to use to share
and pass along information.
There are whole businesses
wholly built off
of having an API.
The ability to
say, hey, I've got
some proprietary
unique information.
I will sell you
access to my API.
You can request it.
You can do whatever you
want with it downstream,
but I'm just building an API.
For that matter, OpenAI
has a really popular API
at this point.
If you just search
OpenAI, API, you
can come to their documentation.
And this has
basically every tool,
every feature you
have in OpenAI,
whether it be ChatGPT,
DALL-E image generation.
All those sorts of things,
they offer them as APIs
so that I don't
have to actually--
if I want to embed
ChatGPT in my website,
or if I'm, again,
Airbnb, and I want
to add descriptions
of the surrounding
area for every listing,
I can just quickly
pass the request over to
OpenAI with the prompt
or however I wanted to do it.
And then OpenAI will
return me that information.
There are tons of
businesses that
have pivoted their
models over to,
hey, we just tap
into the open API.
So for better or
worse, there are
a lot of reasons to understand
fundamentally what an API does.
And while using
them as one aspect,
and you're going to use them
in a lot of other courses,
we're going to talk about
what goes into building them.
Because it's not actually too
much of an extension from what
we've done so far as far
as building a website goes.
So if you pull back up your
terminal here or launch
an EC2 instance,
that's where we're
going to be building off of.
What you see here
right now on my screen
is the history of all of my
commands that I've run so far.
So this is a brand
new EC2 instance.
It's running Ubuntu 22.04.
The only other thing I've
done is run these 12 commands
in this order.
So I cleared out the
history just so it wasn't
a bunch of text on the screen.
Sudo apt update.
And then you'll notice here that
I'm running the exact same steps
to install flask.
So get PIP.
We installed PIP, we installed
virtual environments,
we created a virtual
environment, activated it,
and then I installed flask.
That's exactly where
I'm at right now.
So if you need to pause right
here to get up to speed, great.
Do that.
And then we'll go from there.
So building off of this, first
thing I'm going to do as usual
is I'm going to
make a directory.
I'm going to call it F1
API because we're going
to build a formula one API.
I'm erasing and car nerd.
So we're going to do
everything formula
one themed here for today.
So F1 API.
And we're going to
cd over to that.
So then to build the API,
it's not too different than
or dissimilar from what we've
done before where we say,
OK, let's do nano.
And then rather
than doing app.py,
we're just going
to call it api.py.
You can call it
whatever you want.
This is just so it's very
clear what we're doing.
So now we have a blank flask
document, or a blank Python
file.
And we're going to make
it a Flask application.
So, again, Flask
is just a framework
for building web applications.
And we can either have it
be a website, a web app,
or it can be an API,
or many other things.
So that's the only
reason we're using Flask.
Then we'll set app equals
flask dot flask name.
And this is all the same
things we've done before.
If you want context for
why we're doing what
for this part of it, we talked
about in our first discussion
on building Flask applications.
We're going to add
another line here.
App.config bracket parentheses
all caps debug equals true.
What that'll do is
if we hit an error,
it'll display a debug a
log of what the errors are
or what caused the error
assuming it's a Python error.
The reason this is nice
is that if we have issues
and we are trying to fix them
constantly back and forth,
we don't have to actually
look at the terminal.
We can just see them
right here, or we
can see them on our website.
It'll display the
log of the errors.
The reason you wouldn't want
to have this on, though,
for a production
environment is that if we
had this in our
production environment,
then any user that hit--
Have you ever seen like a
404 page error or whatever,
400 number page error,
this would display
why that error happened.
So we'd basically be
showing our code for that.
Which can be a security risk.
It's showing how your
website's exactly built.
So, for security reasons,
we wouldn't actually
leave this live or
debug equals true.
We'd change that to
false or leave it
as the default, which is false.
But right now,
it's helpful for us
to have this in the
development phase.
But then, otherwise,
the rest of this
is exactly like
we've done before.
So we'll do at app.route.
And then we'll say
here in our home route,
we're going to specify
that this is a get method.
So what that means is that
there are a slew of different
or they're basically four
different types of API methods.
We have post get put and delete.
If you're very familiar
with database development,
these correspond with
our four common actions
in databases which are create,
read, update, and delete.
So post is create.
But post the way we're
going to use it is--
or we would use it.
We're not going to do
a POST method in this.
Is if we had something
where we wanted the user
to pass on information to us.
To upload information,
share information.
So, for example, if you
were building a weather API,
you might want them to post
their zip code so you know
exactly where they're at first.
So that's what a POST method is
similar to create in a database.
Get is like read.
It's saying, hey, let
me get this information.
So I'm going to
pass the request.
I'm going to pass some
parameters in the URL.
Those are going to be
like my query parameters.
And that's how I'm going to get
those bits of information back.
We have put, which is
the equivalent of update.
So I'm updating something
about the database
or updating some information.
And then we have delete, which
is the same in our database
as well to delete information.
Be careful with that, obviously.
Deleting any information can
be dangerous, or at least
can cause downstream issues.
But in certain contexts, we want
to have a delete method as well.
But in this case,
we're doing a get.
It's going to be a very simple.
We're just going to read some
information off the web app.
So, now, let me go
back to my notes
here so I can have
reference for what
I want to actually put in this.
That's right.
So, first, we need to
actually define the function.
So whenever they come
to the slash method,
we'll just define
that as home for now.
And then all this is going
to say is it's going to 2, 3,
4 return.
And it will return
some HTML that
just says in a bold
header, H1, it's
going to be some F1 driver info.
And then H1 here.
So this is going
to be all header.
And then we'll put a
paragraph, a prototype
API for F1 driver info.
So let's close out
that paragraph tag.
This all still is the same, too.
We could technically, put
this in a template or anything
like that.
But we're just keeping
it all in one for now.
Because also, this
is not actually
making an any complex
API request right here.
All this is doing
is saying, hey,
when they come to
this home directory,
we're just going to
display what this website
or what this API does.
Then we're going
to actually build--
well, actually, first,
yeah, let's test
make sure this works to make
sure all our connections are
right and then we'll
come back and build this.
So first, I'm
going to exit here.
Save it.
Yes.
Then I'm going to come back
over to my console here.
And we need to make sure we
open up the relevant port.
So I'm going to back on
my EC2 instance, here
on the console window security.
And then in the ports, we're
going to click security group.
Edit inbound rules.
And note, first off that I
have this HTTP port open,
port 80 from anywhere.
So that's what that IPv4
address stands for 0.00.00/0.
So make sure you have that one.
If you don't have that one,
you can just click Add Rule.
And click where is it at?
There we go.
HTTP.
Or you could have done
custom and put 80 in there.
And then you'll
just specify 0.0.0.
So if you didn't have that
one already, you can add that.
But we will need to add.
So add rule custom
TCP port $5,000.
And we'll add that.
Because remember, flask defaults
to port $5,000 where it deploys
to.
So with that set there, then
we can come back over here.
And we are going to go to--
let me get my notes back here.
There we go.
So we'll get our notes back up.
And then we're going to do
export Flask app equals api.py.
Remember, this is just
setting our default flask app
to be api.py.
So that we can just run flask
run host equals 0.0.0.0.
We should see that
everything worked there.
Then coming back to our EC2
instance to our console,
we'll grab our--
so click EC2.
Go back to our instance.
This is the server
I was running.
We're going to grab this
public IPv4 address,
or you could grab the DNS
name that works as well.
In a new tab, we'll do that.
Colon $5,000.
And boom, you should see that.
If you don't see
that, that means
you have some
error in your code.
Or in the setup
process, if you're
getting an error
where it says, it
can't access it or access
forbidden, something like that.
And if your terminal
looks just like this
or it doesn't show
any errors, then you
know that, OK, there's some
issue with maybe the security
group or something in my setup.
If you come here though,
and it throws a Python error
of some sort, then you
know that it's just
an error in my Python code.
And make sure that if we
go back into our code here,
I just did Control
C to cancel that.
But if we go back into our code,
it should look like this so far.
So make sure all that's working.
And then we can
continue on from here.
So, continuing on,
assuming that worked.
We're going to now
add into our code
from flask import
request and jsonify.
We'll come back to what
those mean in a second.
But first, I want to
add some test data here.
So, again, like I said,
our goal with APIs
is to really have a place where
we can very easily pass along
or share information.
So one way to do that
is to, well, later on,
we'll see how we can pull
data from a database.
That's going to be the
appropriate way to do it.
But we're just going to put
some raw data in here, embed
it directly into
our code base here.
So this will serve
as a placeholder
for what we would
actually do, which
is connect to some database.
So I'm going to add a bunch
of driver data in here.
So information about
drivers in Formula 1.
So let's do this in a lazy way.
So this should work.
Let me copy and paste it here.
This doesn't work.
Then I will do it
a different way.
There we go.
So this is all on Canvas.
I'll make sure it's
linked in the notes
there, just so you don't have
to type all of these details.
This is me putting
some placeholder data
in from a past season.
This is not current
formula 1 race data.
The points scores or point
totals are different right now.
But this saves me having
to type all of this.
And you watch me
type all of this.
But you can pause it and
type it all in as well.
All we did here is create an
object, specifically a list.
So it's a square bracket.
So that means a list in Python.
And again, if you aren't
familiar with Python
programming, you're welcome
to just copy and paste this
and ignore the details of it.
But we created a list, assigned
it to this drivers object.
Within this list, we
had some dictionaries.
So, remember,
dictionaries are defined
by these little curly braces.
So we had three
dictionaries representing
three different drivers.
We've arbitrarily
assigned them ID numbers.
We put their name in there.
So this is Lewis Hamilton.
He was born in 1995.
This is the team he
drives for where he
was driving for at this time.
And then these are the
point totals for that time.
Same thing here.
We have another
driver, Max Verstappen.
His ID that we've arbitrarily
assigned the year team
points yada, yada, yada.
So this defines our data object.
And again, this is not important
or relevant to the process.
This is just our
placeholder data
to replicate what we
would actually do,
which is have this connected
to a database, which
we'll do in a later time.
But this gives us now
some data to surface.
So that if a user
comes to our website
and wants to grab some
information about Formula 1,
this is what we're going
to basically tap into.
So, now, we need to
create an endpoint, which
is the technical term for
this that the user can
access this data from.
So we're going to
say @app.route.
And then we're going to specify
a little bit of a long URL here,
but it's going to help the user
know what specific information
they're going to be grabbing.
So we'll say, OK,
api/vi/resources/f1/all' ,
methods=('GET').
And you'll notice
this in most APIs
is that they'll have a
very clear URL pattern.
Just clarify what
you're grabbing.
So you can see here when you
come to our website now our IP
address, :5000/api then
now we're hitting the api,
we're hitting
version 1 of our api.
We're hitting this bucket.
We've called resources.
We're hitting the f1 data.
And specifically, we're
returning all the information
from this.
So this is going
to be just a call
to say, hey, give me all
the information back out
of the drivers.
We're not even going to be
filtering it down at all.
And you would define
this sort of information
in the documentation.
So all api's will have
documentation that goes along
with it that clarifies what
each of the endpoints do
and what options
you have available.
Here, we're saying
there's no options.
This is just you're going to
return all the information.
So let's define this
function and call it api_all.
And then we're just
going to return.
Jsonify of the drivers object.
If you're not familiar with
json information or json files,
it is a file type.
We'll just come here.
And we'll just search json
on the Wikipedia page.
That's good info on it.
It gives a good
example, I think.
Here, yeah, so
this is a perfect.
So you'll see this looks very
familiar to what we just saw.
Json strings look very similar
to Python dictionaries.
Effectively are the same
thing, but the important detail
is json is a very specific
syntax that stands
for JavaScript
object notation, has
a long history related to being
built in support of JavaScript.
Again, you're welcome
to read the Wikipedia
page on all the history on it.
The important
detail is that this
has become a pretty widely
accepted standard for passing
along information on the web.
The reason is it's very
easy for humans to read.
I can see that OK, this is
defining a single object,
some sort of user, a person.
It has their name,
first name, last name.
Whether they're alive
or not, their age.
Their address is a
nested json string
here or in the
Python terminology,
a nested dictionary.
And it has the
address object which
contains the street
address, the city, the state
and the postal code.
And again, while it's
easy for a human to read,
it's also equivalently easy
for a computer to read.
As long as I know that these are
the fields that are always going
to exist, well, then I can write
an application that easily just
taps in and says, hey, grab the
first name from this response
because I'm going to-- the user
is going to request and say,
hey, I want to pull up maybe--
maybe this is some sort
of contact application.
I want to pull up all the
information about John Smith.
Well, they're going to request
all information about John
Smith.
I'll return this or the api
would return this object,
this json object.
And I could then very easily
parse this in the application
and say, OK, well, the
first name is John.
The last name is Smith.
I know they're alive or not
because these aspects, what
we would call in
Python, the keys,
these are not going to change.
That's basically an
accepted standard.
Or if it does change, it'll
be in the documentation
very clearly.
If I go back really
quick to the OpenAI API,
you'll see this here,
for example, that where
do they show it at?
Here, somewhere in
here they show the--
this is an irrelevant aside, so
don't worry too much about this
if I don't get this
pulled up here, that's
a quick starter overview.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Hopefully, I think this is
what I'm looking for here.
Yes.
So you can see here
that for OpenAI, they
have a similar thing.
Now, they're passing these or
actually you can see it here.
So this is what their OpenAI is.
One of their API endpoints
looks like is api.openai.com/v
1/chat/completions.
Then they got a bunch of options
that they're tagging on to this.
But this is basically saying,
hey, I want to do a chat.
And then what they
return is a json object.
So they pass along
this message and then
this is the object that returns.
So this is the same
idea we're building.
This is just a more
complicated example.
But anyway, that's what jsonify
does as a Python function.
Notice it's coming out of the
flask library, and it'll turn
or it'll try to coerce
objects into json.
Not everything can be naturally
coerced or coerced into json,
but if it can be, it will be.
Dictionaries, very
easily because again,
this is the exact same format
as we saw with the other ones.
So let's check to
make sure that works.
So we'll do control X. Yes.
Save.
Now, let's relaunch
our application.
And you can already
see this is what
it looks like when you get
an error in the Python code
is that it didn't
even launch for me,
and it's very clear
what it said and there's
no module named flaks.
So typo on that one.
So let's go here.
I'm sure you guys are all
screaming at the screen telling
me that I made a mistake.
Hopefully.
All right.
Now let's see if I
did a better job.
OK.
No immediate errors.
So let's go back
over to our website.
And then I'll just refresh this.
Make sure that it's not https.
It defaults to that
a lot of times.
So if you hit an error,
error comes up to this page,
say it can't provide
a secure connection.
That means it was trying to
connect to a secure website.
We did not build a
secure website yet.
So just remove that S, and
it should just be http:// IP
address :5000.
And remember, that's putting us
at the default home location,
which just shows this.
Now, if want to get the relevant
information or all the driver
information, we'll
/api/v1/resourse/f1/all.
And boom.
There we go.
It is now returned to us.
Our whole or all the
information in our json format
might even have this option
depending on your browser.
It's going to be browser
specific to print it prettier.
Though even if
you don't, there's
plenty of json
formatters online that'll
print this out into a
nice format with dropdowns
and everything like that.
So you can just search like
json object view or copy
and paste the long string
into there and that'll return
or that'll let you
show it a nicer format.
But importantly now, we've
basically built a business.
Our business is to take
this proprietary information
that maybe nobody else has ever
collected about our f1 drivers
and their year they're born
and the number of points.
They have in their team.
And we've now made it
public to the world.
If I were to leave
this website live now,
you could do this and
pull this information
into any sort of
downstream application.
So very, very
valuable, especially
if you're building
a business wholly
based on proprietary
information.
This is a way that you can
effectively monetize it.
And what'll actually
happen is so, for example,
like with OpenAI, they
charge you per API call,
so they'll make you have
a special API key that
is unique to your profile so
that they know how many calls
is this person making or how
much information are they asking
us to return to them.
And then I'll just charge
them based off of that.
Or maybe I'll say, hey,
you're limited to X number
of calls at your tier?
But otherwise I don't have
to build any front end
interface now.
Like that's for you to do.
My business was just
providing information.
APIs are super nice for that.
OK.
So let's keep going on this.
We'll ignore all
this output here.
Let's just type clear.
So control C to stop
the app from running
clear to dump that back out.
So we can see a little easier.
Now let's-- go back out here.
And it just not want
to-- there we go.
Now we'll go back here.
And we'll go back
into our application.
So nano api.py.
And now, I want to
create an endpoint that
allows the user to
make a request that
is dependent upon some field.
So maybe I want to have them.
They don't want to return all
the information every time
because that would require us
dumping out our whole database.
That takes way too long if we
have some massive database.
I want to only return
specific information.
Or maybe it's that
they only have access
to specific information.
So I'm going to limit that
right what they can access.
So we'll say at @app.route.
Now we'll create a new
endpoint that just says
api/v1/resources/f1.
But we're not doing
all at the end.
Still a GET method.
And then we're going to say
this one is called api id.
So we're going to assume they're
making a request based off
of the id.
Then what we'll do is we'll
say, OK, if id is in or just
in request.args.
id=int(request.args('id'))
Oh, my gosh, type in id.
And then we'll say
do report else--
return error no
ID field provided.
Please specify an ID.
So what this says now-- so far,
we're not done with the function
yet.
But what this says so far
is let's first just check
to make sure they passed an ID.
If they didn't pass an
ID, then they probably
should have used all
endpoint to just return
everything or some
other endpoint
that we haven't defined yet.
So first, we're going
to check to see if they
passed an ID in the request.
Well, we can grab that and we'll
see how we can actually pass it
in a request in a second.
But once we figure
out how to do that,
we can grab any arguments
from the request
by just using this
special request.args here.
So this says, hey, check
to see if there's anything
called ID in the request.args.
If not or if there
is, then we're
going to turn that
into an integer value
because that's how we're
referencing them up here
as integers, not as strings.
Anything in the quotes
here is as a string.
So we want it as an integer.
So we're just coercing
it to be an integer.
Then we'll say, if
not though, we're
going to just warn them and say,
hey, you didn't provide an ID
field, you should specify one.
So that's all that this
first line is doing.
This line also, coercing
it into an integer,
is also a nice way
for us to ensure
that they don't pass any sort of
malicious information to this.
There is a whole other
side to of the security
of how you can create a secure
API or a secure API endpoints.
So that we don't
allow, for example,
them to inject any information
into our application
or request any information that
they maybe don't have access to.
We are not getting
into that at all.
That's well, well beyond
the scope of this course.
But just know that if you're
interested in the security
side of this, there's a whole
well, you can go down for it.
But either way, we've
got now our first check
just to make sure
that they are actually
requesting some information.
Then I will create an empty
list to store the results in.
And then to create
the results, we're
going to do this a lazy way.
We're just going to iterate over
all the drivers in our driver's
list.
And then we're going to
say if they requested
a specific driver's id.
So if the driver id
is equal to the id
object that we created above
that was from the request.
Then we're going to say
results.append(driver).
So if the driver of
interest was in the request,
then we'll append
them to this list
and we can append any other
drivers they requested.
And then once we've iterated
through all drivers in our list,
we will return the jsonify
of our results list.
Like I said, this is a very
lazy way to write this.
If you are a Python developer,
you're screaming at the screen
because I could have done this
significantly more efficiently.
We're going for clarity
here, not efficiency.
And I would argue
a lot of times when
you're building your website
or building something new out,
I would always go
for clarity first
and then I work towards
efficiency because it's
important to make sure it
works and that you know
you can confirm it works and
works the way you expect,
and then you can always back out
and make aspects of it faster.
So let's save this
and test this.
OK.
So we didn't have any
initial Python errors.
That's a good sign.
So let's come over here.
Let's check that
this one still works.
OK.
That old API call still
works of passing all.
But now, we want to
see, well, how do we
pass some sort of
argument in our requests?
Well, the way you do
that is OK, f1 was we
didn't specify an
id, that's an error.
That means our code
is working so far.
Then I would do question mark
at the end of my URL there.
And I would say, for
example, id equals 1.
And that will return
just the one thing
because it said, OK,
there was an ID argument
and then I passed some
number after that.
And so you can see from just
this very, very simple framing,
this very simple idea, we
now have the capability
to really build out any
features we want to write.
As we'll see in a
future video, we're
going to actually tap into
this and leverage the fact
that we can build databases
to efficiently store
this information, so we
can just straight query it.
So rather than having
in our code here like
we have at this point, which
is a bunch of just driver
information stored in here,
and then we have in this just
us filtering through from this
data or from this dictionary.
Instead we can say,
well, why don't we
just query our database directly
within this code based off
of the ID?
And hopefully, that
highlights in your head
all the myriad things we
could do at this point.
So we'll leave it at this.
Like I said, in a
future video, we
will talk about how we can use
this to query from a database.
But otherwise, feel free
to play around with this.
Hopefully, it elucidates
some things that work
or how some things
work on the web.
You're welcome to look at
some other databases that
exist already.
You might even also
see, hey, for example,
this is how I can start to
see how certain websites know
what information to pull
by using this question mark
and grabbing the
arguments out of there.
So we're just pulling
back the layers
on how the internet
works slowly,
and then we'll
build up from there.
So I'll talk to you next time.
Hopefully this was helpful.
Bye.